I'm making two more changes to my
youtube schedule don't kill me hey guys
so I'm making two changes to the YouTube
channel that I hope you will enjoy and
that one of it is based off of feedback
from you guys and one of it is based off
of my own desires and ambitions so the
first one is around a lot of requests
you guys have had to say hey can you
please cover the top lessons for women
entrepreneurs or black entrepreneurs or
student entrepreneurs or tech
entrepreneurs or industry-specific
entrepreneurs and we haven't really had
a spot to be able to do that and so what
I'm going to be doing is taking out one
of the top tens per week and replacing
it with the top 50 so the one coming out
today it going to be for the top 50
rules for success for women
entrepreneurs and I love your feedback
on what other themes and topics you guys
want me to do so that we can put this
kind of mass collaboration together the
second one is going to be around the
environment series that I had the idea
behind environment was that we pull
together all of these different
successful rules from successful
entrepreneurs and you could play it
during the day and it would allow you to
be surrounded by greatness right your
environment sucks that holds you where
you are to break out you have to have a
great environment so this was the idea
that not consume it actively where you
watch it the past is gonna have it on in
the background while you do your stuff I
found two things one that you guys
didn't resonate with that message so
well you're watching videos more
actively and it wasn't on during the day
and two more importantly maybe I found
that I was in consuming that's the fleet
during the day right I wasn't watching
my own stuff and I felt well that's
that's a problem and so what I'm going
to be doing is changing it up to have
different sets of music for
entrepreneurs to listen to during the
day I've been doing a lot of research on
music some music is better for
concentration and productivity some of
it is better for creativity and so on
and so I'm going to be I'm going to be
eating my own dog food and testing this
out on myself first when I'm working on
different tasks does this music help me
or not and if I can get to the point
where it is i'm going to be swapping out
the end
environment on the weekends and
replacing it with a music series that I
think will help because we need to
listen to soft during the day to get us
in our zone and help us work on our
projects so those are the two changes
that are coming I hope you enjoy them I
promise I won't release anything until I
actually love it myself as well I'd love
to know what you think leaving the
comments below and if you have other
suggestions for me too I'm always open
to hearing your thoughts thank you guys
so much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon